this episode of gam spots holiday gift
guide is presented by Sony Entertainment
Network get $15 credit for spending $100
visit sony.com for details hello and
welcome to gamespot's holiday gift guide
I'm Jeff Canada today we're running down
the top five games to get for that game
collector on your list this is the kind
of gamer who wants the Ultimate
Experience who proudly displays his or
her collection of games on the shelf and
has to have the biggest and the baddest
versions to show off the first game on
our list is Disney Infinity Marvel
Superheroes 2.0 edition starter pack
collector's edition not only is the
title am mouthful but this package
weighs in at a hefty
$180 and what do you get for all that
scratch well Disney Infiniti is more
than just a video game it's actually
built around collecting dozens of Disney
character figurines which can be brought
into the digital game Game World this
collector's edition has all of the
Avengers from the film Captain America
Thor Iron Man Hulk Black Widow Hawkeye
all of them as well as a massive Frost
Beast display stand to show them off it
also contains a poster and a vengers
playset piece and lots more if you're
buying for a game collector clamoring to
play Bungie's newest space epic you
can't do better than this epic package
for 150 bucks you'll get tons of digital
extras like gear to outfit your
character and a full season pass for
upcoming expansion content plus physical
goodies like a steelbook case a patch
and a star chart but the real kicker is
the full-size replica of the ghost
companion from the game complete with a
motion sensor lights and authentic
sounds from
Destiny fans of the Juggernaut Call of
Duty series have got to be excited about
the atlas Edition for the newest
Advanced world Warfare the massive
amounts of digital content in this $120
package include costumes and unique
Weaponry a full season pass for map
packs and expansions and even a special
in-game calling card to strike fear in
the hearts of your enemies it also
includes an advanced sulter guide for
maximizing your skills a map and steel
case and the game's soundtrack on CD
ubisoft's $130 Far Cry 4 kirat edition
might be the perfect addition to their
shelf it's got a propaganda poster and
physical game map several exclusive
bonus missions and weapons and a full
leatherbound journal to record your
adventures to top things off there's
also an extraordinarily creepy 20cm
figurine of the game's lead villain
Pagan Min Seated on an elephant
Throne as a huge RPG fan myself and a
fan of Dragon Age the
$170 Uber Edition has got me salivating
the case alone is a work of art it's
gigantic wrapped in a faux reptile skin
has the mark of the Inquisitor stamped
on top in gold foil and the interior is
fitted with imprinted red silk not to
mention it comes with a cloth map a
40-page journal physical coins a real
quill and ink pot and get this a
fullscale six tool lock pick set
there you have it five of the most
collectible packages in gaming this year
and five ways to make the collector on
your list extremely happy tune in next
time when we'll be running down the top
five indie games I'm Jeff Canada thanks
for
watching